So let's talk about divided attention.
>> You know, I'm going to tell you a little story
about dorm room Debbie from lesson two. And we're going to
talk about how we create a great experience to not
violate the constraint of our users having a divided attention. So
imagine we have dorm room Debbie, she's late for class.
With a latte in one hand, her smart phone in
the other hand, and carrying a lot of books. On
her way to class she has to cross several busy streets,
so her attention is very split between all these things. Then she gets
a notification on her Android smart phone. It's from her library app, telling
her she has a book overdue. So imagine you made this library app
for Debbie. How would you notify her that her library books are overdue?